et has learned david letterman's mother  Dorothy has died she was 95 years old  dorothy was a regular guest on her son's  late-night show and reportedly made her  first appearance on the talk-show  during the 1994 Winter Olympics she  later made annual Mother's Day visits  and appeared in a special Thanksgiving  segment called guess mom's pie all right  mom  it's time to guess the the pie and I can  see they're covered up mom just tell me  do you have well there are traditional  American Thanksgiving pies today yes I  do  nothing wacky well there might be one  wacky Oh for the love of all right in  1996 the legendary late-night host mom  also published a cookbook titled home  cooking with Dave's mom the sad news of  her death comes just one day before  Letterman 70th birthday  [Music]